[Music]
antonio is with us in
charlotte north carolina hey antonio
what's up in your world
hey dave how are you can you hear me
okay absolutely sir
how can we help um i'm happy i found you
um about a year and a half ago
i feel like i made a kind of terrible
terrible decision
um i was down to my last two deaths on
baby step two
um i had a personal loan
um with about five fifty three hundred
left and a
car loan that was about fifty three
hundred left uh my car was giving me a
lot of issues
i had gotten a lot of work done to it
and
so i decided to a dealer gave me an
offer more than the blue book value for
it
um so i kind of took that money and um
the money they paid off the rest of the
car i took that money and
paid off the personal loan um so now i'm
you know i was left with you know the
money i was left with instead of going
out and buying a
uh four or five thousand dollar car um i
decided to
go to the dealership and i bought a used
uh
2014 ford escaped about 28 000 miles on
it
um i financed it which was a terrible
idea
um and now i just feel it's the only
debt that i have
um now but i just i just feel terrible
getting into a
finance car for another five years
um interest rate in about a four hundred
dollar car payment
six percent interest rate in the 400 car
payment so
i just wanted to know your thoughts if i
should i got it a week ago
just want to know if you know if you
think it's worth keeping with it being
my only debt now
and just paying off as fast as possible
or
um try to try to sell it
sounds like you need to give up drinking
[Laughter]
i'm kidding but you woke up with a
serious financial hangover didn't you
yeah absolutely terrible decision yeah
so you either go back out partying again
tonight
or you avoid the alcohol because you
gave you a hangover
translation you sell a stupid car dude
yes sir i mean you knew that right i
didn't have to tell you that you just
want me to say it out loud for you
i i i i believe so i felt terrible about
it every time
i'm not going to shame you because i've
done dumber stuff but the trick
is here's the thing what i try to do
when i do something stupid and man i
have i have paid so much stupid text in
my life
i have a phd in dumb man i have done so
many stupid butt stuff
i've done stuff that makes you look like
a genius okay
and you're not okay
but uh so i mean it's okay we've all
been there there's a point now the
question is this
i always ask myself when i do something
stupid and it leaves a mark like this
where i like oh crap that was so dumb
you know what i'm saying i try to like
mark that down in my stupid book
because i'm gonna do something else
stupid i know i am
but i just try not to do the same stupid
thing again
right and what you did here was you
repeated a stupid thing
because you got a car payment in the
first place and you went and traded it
for a different car payment that was
bigger
which is obviously perpendicular to your
goal of being out of debt
so the big lesson here is you looking in
the mirror and going
i'm going to get control of you
that's the big thing you do what you
want to do brother i'm not here to beat
you up i've done dumber like i said but
if i woke up in your shoes i'd sell that
car
this week and then stay off the car lot